[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by best-selling author
and ken coleman the same person did you
know that ken that is true sometimes i
don't believe it i love it well we're
excited to take your call folks triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're here to help you with your money
your work your relationships your life
it's all intertwined here on the ramsay
show sarah's kicking us off in denver
sarah welcome to the
show hey thanks for having me huge fan
of yours of ken's probably right you
meant ken
george she laughed nervously sure i did
that's great sarah how can we help today
yeah so i'm actually traveling on a
business trip right now and i've been
going through dave's baby steps um don't
have a credit card i'm eighteen hundred
dollars away from being out of debt
fully so really excited about that
awesome um on this work trip i kind of
had the worst nightmare flight situation
last night where
everything was canceled how to do a
hotel and the connection flight was only
two hours it's a two-hour drive away so
my boss was like we're gonna cancel that
grab a rental car take it from there to
that city and then just drop it back off
at the
supposed to be city i'm in airport so we
were going through that and the rental
car company was saying because i had a
debit card
um they rejected me because the drop-off
location was different
and my boss who knows i don't have a
credit card was like
very frustrated because i don't have a
company card which as of today i do
through the situation
um but he couldn't authorize it and it
kind of then i had to uber from that
city like it turned out to be a very big
fiasco
so i guess my question is unfortunately
now i have a company card and defended
why i don't have a credit card to my
boss and was like this is work you
should give me this anyway rather than
expense it but has this been a personal
situation just happening to me and i
didn't have one
um is it worth it to get a card if this
happens rather than have to pay more
fees to uber everywhere
well you're seeing it as a binary option
of either i uber everywhere or i have to
get a credit card i don't see it that
way personally because and that's from
personal experience so i i understand
and i agree that it is not a fun
situation for a lot of folks right now
trying to rent a car with a debit card
there are some things you have to be uh
prepared for you got to be intentional
about researching hey what are the
company's debit card policies with you
know who i'm booking with so for example
i rent i rented with enterprise recently
and they allow debit cards they're just
a 20 hold of your total amount that goes
on the card
and so what i want you to do
is do that research
okay i've normally done that because
that's why i did it for this slide it
was actually with enterprise as well but
they just said because the drop-off city
was different they didn't allow it oh
interesting so with that specific policy
yeah i mean i would start to research
different companies and see what their
policies are on different drop-off
locations because normally you're
probably dropping off at the same
location correct
correct okay so i don't want to make a
decision based off a one-off weird fluke
thing and i mean it sounds super
frustrating i'm sorry you went through
that but i also don't want you to go get
a credit card just for
this one instance and go well it didn't
work this one time so i'm going to go
down this path yeah sarah look
it sucks
right
but this isn't going to happen very
often when it does you had an
alternative
and you may not have liked it you may
have spent a little bit more money on
the uber but again this is a rare
situation and george is absolutely right
if you go get the credit card for this
really
rare situation you're just creating a
temptation to actually use it and so you
believe in the principles
remind yourself why you believe in the
principles and also be able to step back
for this and go yes this was a really
nightmarish situation but the reality is
it doesn't happen very often
it did happen
and
two things that i can walk away with
that
convince me i don't need a credit card
number one your boss gave you a company
card so now this isn't gonna be an issue
anymore
period on a personal level
could this scenario happen again yes but
what would you do well you've got cash
and you've got
a debit card and you can uber it's not
the end of the world you can get where
you need to go so don't convince
yourself that you need to do something
you don't believe in for this rare
situation yeah and if you're going on a
trip with friends if that situation
comes up usually your friends are going
all right i got the credit card all
right sweet you book it i'll venmo you
the amount you know if you're splitting
the booking in a situation like that so
there's ways around it with other people
but i get it if you're doing the ramsey
plan can this is one of those things
where you go oh gosh how am i going to
navigate this but a lot of people don't
realize that there's other ways around
it when you don't back yourself into a
corner and go well there's only these
two options i actually have a question
for you uh have you done an analysis are
you just aware of
uh
the difference between a rental car
because rental car costs have gone up if
i'm not mistaken
versus getting an uber so let's say i
land in any city what's the difference
between ubering versus uh
certainly it's gonna be more it depends
on the city you're you're going to and
where you're trying to head is it a huge
discrepancy it can't be so for example
me and my wife who went to san francisco
and you know transportation there we
just decided to do ubers instead of
getting a rental car because i didn't
want the hassle of driving around the
city yeah and it was significantly
cheaper than if we had rented a car
right
and i actually prefer the uber i got to
tell you i don't want to i don't want to
deal with i want to relax on vacation i
want someone else to drive me here i
don't like driving period ken's got to
show us no i don't
it's me it's me guys i'm kidding george
picks me up every morning it's fantastic
it just really builds our bond and uh
you know it's great for my blood the
visual of that is making america very
happy right now yeah i'm honking outside
the kids are waving yeah yeah well you
got the electric car that's so it's a
win for everybody there's some gas
savings there as well yeah i read the
old school newspaper in the back seat
and and george just plays uh cool
hipster music it's a wonderful
experience thank you for that ken yeah
well folks a lot of people would rather
spend their weekend doing yard work than
talk about insurance i know ken
coleman's one of those that's absolutely
true i would rather talk about insurance
than new work so we are opposites in
that regard but here's the deal if you
don't take time to learn about this
stuff you always feel like you're
getting ripped off or making all the
wrong choices about your insurance
around here we think learning about
money should be simple and even fun and
so our new five-day guide to insurance
it's free it's called confidence in your
coverage makes learning about insurance
quick and practical and you might even
laugh out loud a time or two and that's
because i tried really hard to make the
jokes funny ken yeah you do in the
series i tried you know i like to add a
little spice if you will you do you make
it bearable thank you that's my goal
well it's insurance i mean no one's
watching this for entertainment we're
doing this because we need to be
educated agreed so if you're going to do
it why not sign up for this guide it's
called confidence in your coverage every
day for five days i'm gonna walk you
through a new insurance topic unpacking
everything you need to know to get the
right coverage for you these are short
videos under three minutes i get to the
point i make a joke and i get out of
there yeah that's how it should be so at
the end of the series you're still going
to have your yard work i can't help you
with that but at least you'll know your
stuff when it comes to insurance so go
to ramseysolutions.com
confidence to sign up and get started
again that's
slash
ramseysolutions.com
ken i was just on the phone with xander
insurance today oh yeah we've we've had
as an advertiser here for many years
yeah had a great experience working on a
homeowners policy and their level of
knowledge in educating me on why
they're making the decisions saying hey
here's what i think you should do here's
why it gave me actual confidence that i
was making the right decisions with
really big financial moves like your
home owners your auto policy
so sign up for this it's gonna really
help you get more confident that's what
we're here for ramseysolutions.com
confidence open phones this hour triple
a 825-5225
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by ken
coleman this is the ramsay show
you know ken we talk a lot about how
your greatest wealth building tool is
your income and you just got off doing
the ken coleman show helping people
increase their income through their
career that's right which is awesome
well yeah so we want to take those calls
today because again we are staring down
the barrel of a recession people
starting to freak out about it so how
can we help you recession proof
not just your career but just your
income and there's a way to do that and
so obviously as a part of ramsey
solutions i'm the guy that's trying to
help you with that bigger shovel if
that's getting out of debt or how do we
plan for uh potential job layoffs
all these things that are legitimate
concerns for people i'm here today to
help you in those areas if you're in a
toxic environment you want to get out
we'll change your name
your location all that
so that we can help you out so i'm here
today obviously to chime in on all the
money and life calls but um your work
your income is a huge part of your life
and a lot of people have been there's
been a shake up this year last year with
people going i don't know this is what i
want to do i don't think this is the
right career field i'm not making what i
should be making in this market and so a
lot of people are shifting things with
the remote works they're going i can
live anywhere and do anything what would
i do and we've seen a lot of people take
jobs to get a much bigger paycheck which
is obviously makes a lot of sense but
now they're like oh we changed it and
and yeah that wore off and i really want
to enjoy my life and if you think about
how much time we spend at work
versus anything else we do in our life
it is the largest percentage of what we
do and you need to enjoy it and we can
help you do that making more money more
impact so we'll take some of those calls
today any of those calls we can help out
let's do it triple eight eight two five
five two two five irena calls us from st
louis irina welcome to the show
thank you so much guys pleasure to speak
to you about you as well how can we help
so uh we my husband and i we have got a
dilemma uh we are relevant for uh we are
debt-free but our house we do have six
months of emergency plans set aside we
would like to move to florida within the
next year or so uh the house that we
currently live in we love the house we
just finished doing the update we
absolutely love the house but we came to
our realization that we did not
necessarily love the location not
because it's a bad location it's
absolutely not a great location but a
little bit too far from where we like to
be so dilemma is kind of like we're like
okay do we need to
do we want to sell our house now and
possibly go rent for that next year
while we're trying to get ready for that
move do we
sell and maybe reinvest into something
smaller for the time being
still locally but closer to where we
would like to be
uh or do we just don't need to do any of
that and basically stay in the house
until they are ready for that move out
of state um a lot of options here so
you're wanting to move to florida but
there's no real urgency around this move
no okay
well i mean if i'm in your shoes there's
no real reason to sell right now and
rent and do all of that unless you're
actually moving i know you're you're
saying you want to be closer to some
things i don't know if that's more of a
you know the a different district where
there's more going on restaurants and
things like are you kind of tucked away
in the suburbs right now
yeah yeah like pretty much for this uh
furthest you know in i mean it's a great
it's a great area it's a great location
it's a great
subdivision like everything about it is
good but it's just far and you just
finished all these updates too
yes yes i mean if i'm you guys i'm just
staying put and i'm going to use the the
fuel of wanting to get out of there to
then move to florida sooner
what do you think ken yeah i i want to
dive a little deeper irena in what's
what's driving us to florida what why
that destination what do we what's that
future that we're looking forward to
explain that to me
uh well uh uh basically we used to live
there and ideally we want to uh kind of
grow i mean we have one son we have
planning you know second kid
ideally that's where we want to end up
also my parents live in california so
it's not necessarily ideal for them to
move to missouri but we want to be all
closer so we all agreed that florida
would be a great destination for all of
us yeah so uh
okay and then what uh what what makes
you feel ready to move to florida well
what would what would that look like or
feel like
okay now we're ready
well uh so i'm i'm self-employed i work
in real estate but i've been building my
other side of business in real estate
industry but
that would allow me to work remotely so
it's not necessarily uh at the point
where like okay we're good to go income
is completely 100 guaranteed but it's
it's going well it's i'm working on my
clientele so that's where we're kind of
like okay we can do it right now but
ideally i want to be in a place where i
can
100 you know pretty much you know as
much as i can guarantee my income to
continue flowing and
being from a different not being local
being you know working remotely
essentially and my husband at that time
would be able to uh get a good position
uh that he's working toward uh also in
florida as well in the industry that
he's working in yeah so i mean i think
george is right i just think you get to
decide there's never an ideal time i
certainly understand what you mean you
know we'd like this to be true and this
to be true and this to be true but life
can sometimes uh throw us some
curveballs isn't that true irena so you
know
this is a good time to sell
but you know i will also tell you that
that's where the dilemma came from well
but let me that's what i thought might
be there so george we were talking about
this earlier today with real estate with
our real estate team
so uh the concern is that because of a
impending recession
which
may or may not happen some are
predicting that it'll happen you know
who knows
um and that real estate rates excuse me
interest rates have gone up that all of
a sudden housing is just going to drop
precipitously and six months from now
which might be ideal for you you're
gonna be like oh it was a bad financial
decision and all the real estate experts
in our building uh plus i saw the the
caldwell banker ceo uh on cnbc earlier
this week saying that right now we still
see a huge demand we have a gap of five
to six million houses
uh in this economy where that's what the
supply would need to be
to just get back to a normal area so the
point is the demand is still high
what you're hearing is and may be seeing
in your area
is that the listing price for some
houses is scaling back a little bit but
that doesn't mean that housing and and
the gains that people are going to make
are just all of a sudden dropping
through the basement does that make
sense
yes so don't panic you're still going to
make good meaning the realtor i know
it's like i i i've been saying oh i
don't think it's going to drop out but
it's basically kind of you felt like
okay this is a peak and we potentially
could get a lot but also that that
that's the whole aspect of like well
shoot we live so far from everything
like we just kind of like we just live
far and we don't you know we're no
longer in love with this location so
that's you're like what do you mean you
know just move mom you know temporary or
not at all you know if it's me and and i
would if i had already determined what
you just shared
that you don't love where you live i'd
make the move
because you're already set up
so i think it's up to you what i think i
think if you make the move it will delay
the florida move further because you're
not going to move to a different house
yeah and then you move a year from then
i mean there's a lot of costs involved
with this there's a lot of hassle
involved so i think if you move you're
probably planning to stay there for you
know two three four five years before
florida and that's okay but just paint a
realistic picture so you're not
frustrated if you do this
right
it's not really a wrong decision it just
really depends on your expectations of
the future that's right and i think
style and temperament work into this as
well yes um you know i'ma rip the
band-aid guy off i mean i just am like
once i arrive at a decision it's like
okay i
i'm gonna make what happens is sometimes
you spend a longer time just percolating
on this decision than the actual time it
would take to make it and do it and act
on it yeah
so i think there's a lot of uh wisdom in
that yeah as well yeah but we are seeing
some crazy things in the real estate
market ken and uh we're pumped to do
this free livestream event coming up and
they've been around has been amazing
tell these folks about it many many
thousands of you already signed up so on
july 14th we are hosting a free live
stream event called real estate reality
check so myself rachel cruz dave ramsey
we're going to walk you through what's
going on in the housing market today and
explain how it works and here's the deal
the housing market is not going to crash
and we're going to show you why this is
not just our opinion this is we're not
just out of touch here yep so we want to
uh make sure you join us for this it's
completely free maybe you're looking to
buy or sell a home you're wondering if
it's going to crash what's causing all
of this july 14th is when you're going
to find out go sign up
ramseysolutions.com
reality check
and we just added this morning i'm going
to be doing a 20-minute pre-show with
sock puppets you know what i mean you
know what ken someone's going to sign up
and be upset that that is not true okay
i'm ju i'm jester that's a separate live
stream if you're into those sock dm ken
coleman on instagram let him know
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
let's
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman is my co-host today i'm
george campbell you're listening to the
ramsay show
you know ken we have a venn diagram and
my world is you know it's money stuff
and your world is career but also you
love sports
and so today the venn diagram finally
meets in the middle
because we have an article here that is
connecting the sports world to the money
world oh you ready for this oh this is
fascinating i'm very excited here's the
headline from
firstsports.com with a z
take take that with a grain of salt
again here's the headphones you'd be
very gentle with george because he's
entering into completely unknown
territory right now if i biff some
sports names please i'm here for you all
right here's the headline okay quote bad
investment odell beckham jr's 750 000
contract just worth over 35 000
after bitcoin plummets
well so that tells me he had a contract
that was bitcoin infused he signed a
one-year deal with the rams that can pay
him up to 4.25 million dollars with the
majority of the deal being heavily based
upon incentives and it was ultimately a
one-year 1.25 million dollar deal with a
750 base salary 750 how much of that was
bitcoin
um it looks like the 750. wow that was a
bad move obj here's what it's saying
people call him obj in this football
world this helps me out okay immensely i
didn't want to confuse you uh but yeah
it says uh beckham took his salary in
bitcoin oh that's he took to twitter to
announce his bold move to take salary
and crypto yeah sure he said it's the
start of a new era i'm looking forward
to the future however obj's move just
backfired because according to sports
business analyst darren rovell did i get
that right yeah very good very good the
beckham contract is only worth
nine hundred 412
fifty three dollars here's the sad news
after factoring in the taxes which is
based on the original amount obj will be
left with just over thirty five thousand
dollars so he only got a bit of that
contract i see what you did there he'll
be here all week folks the dad jokes
come out of me every once in a while
folks i apologize james is one more dad
joke away from muting you okay be nice
james i apologize but it was kind of
relevant bitcoin bit of his contract i
loved it son ford thank you for now uh
this is happening across the board we
can pick on obj also so you're a big
crypto uh you follow this you follow the
news you're a bit of a uh yeah what
would i call you you're a bit of a a
crypto
uh crypto curious yes you're a crypto
curious yes well
i get questions about this a lot from
our fans from our audience going hey is
this a good idea i saw this what
so i've had to look into it we did an
episode on the fine print all about
cryptocurrency and bitcoin and here's
the thing i'm not mad at bitcoin every
time we talk about cryptocurrency the
crypto bros come at us and they're angry
because we don't understand and it's the
future and the blockchain is the
technology's amazing seems like a scary
bunch
they are very the crypto bros i will say
this they make the mlm folks look soft
and that is saying something wow
multi-level marketing yeah
george is firing i don't want your
tupperware okay i got plenty of it uh so
is it because the reason that this is so
scary
is because it is so wildly
uh speculative in that it's volatile up
down and so you know it's down 60
percent yeah it keeps crashing down and
listen it'll it'll probably go back up
but then it's going to crash immensely
and this roller coaster it doesn't have
the proven traffic i tell you one of the
problems george you got matt damon you
got matt damon telling me
that i'm that i'm not brave if i don't
jump into this be brave i'm watching him
he's talking about the fortune favors
the brave and i'm sitting there on the
couch watching i love goodwill hunting
as much as the next guy but see
celebrities pitching crypto this is my
point and even the media outlets can
have been going after the celebrities
because
there's no recourse for this celebrities
are just blindly endorsing crypto for
oodles of money and then when crypto
crashes the celebrities aren't out there
saying sorry i was wrong yeah
so this is a big problem we're not
anti-crypto
we're just saying this is not a smart
financial move right now given the the
fact that it is is relatively uh brand
new i mean this is still in its infancy
if you will and uh regulations and the
fact that it's not recognized across the
board you know a lot of stuff here be
careful be very careful especially if
you are a pro athlete listening which
i'm sure there's so many out there wow i
mean if dave said hey ken i'm going to
start paying you in bitcoin now hell
would have to freeze over for that to
happen yeah but if that happened i would
go no i'll take i'll take money i'll
take real
dollars in my bank account i think my
first reaction would be what did obj do
no i'm kidding there we go hey this is
very exciting we got to talk about
bitcoin and you learned who odell
beckham jr is which is fantastic
usually i learned something you learn
something this is great all of my sports
knowledge comes from the original space
jam movie ken as you know so in my mind
patrick ewing is still hot on the courts
yeah we were actually talking about this
uh pre-show today and we were we said we
were going to talk about this and george
says well ken i need you to pipe in
because i don't know much about sports
players
i want to leave that with the audience
that's what they're called not all of
them are athletes i mean have you seen
soccer sports they're actors not
athletes i went to my first soccer game
that's actually gonna offend a lot of
people soccer is a
worldwide sport that's careful george
i'm just saying i went to the nashville
soccer club game and it was there was a
lot of did you sing and yell with the
group the whole time they were all
yelling different things profanities and
such i'm not gonna be involved in that i
have class i do love the vu vezuela you
know that is that how you say it yeah i
think it's called vu vezuel if i'm
saying that correctly yeah that noise
alone oh i love his way that's reason to
never go to the side
i just said it three times in 10 seconds
i'm hearing vavuzila is the
is it vavuzela
all right we'll look it up we'll get to
the calls we'll come back with that for
the three people who are still listening
to the show uh thank you for joining us
we're gonna take a call now yeah from
joseph in henderson uh nevada let's do
it nevada nevada are you a nevada guy i
think it's nevada let's ask joseph what
he thinks about this joseph are you team
nevada or nevada how's it going i am in
henderson nevada yes very close to
nevada maybe five to ten minutes yeah
there we go all right
all right what's your question joseph
hi so i'm 17 years old i'm just starting
my life hey speak directly in your phone
for me joseph you you got a little
squirrel you hear me there we go can you
hear me yes so i'm 17 years old and you
know i just got out of high school
graduated and i have a total of three
thousand dollars saved up and my friends
are pressuring me now
to get a credit card and my uncle's a
huge dave ramsey fan and i started
listening to dave ramsey behind that and
when i get off track i listen but
everyone's pressuring me now to apply
for that nevada state bank
city double cash card or whatever it is
and i'm very strict on no i don't want
to do that even my own mom
has been trying to convince me of you
know you can apply for a credit card and
they don't have a very good i mean 10
years ago
now they're much better i mean granted
we're in a way better place than we were
10 years ago we were in so much credit
card debt we didn't go on vacation for
seven years we paid it all off and now
all we owe is our house mortgage and
that's all the debt that we have left
but yeah that's they're all pressuring
me and i just don't know how to respond
to them and then
another thing is you know
i want to be on the path toward not
having to waste 10 years of my life
being stuck in this miserable desert not
going on vacation so i want to be able
to be wealthy all right so joseph let me
let me make sure i'm understanding
you're convicted and convinced because
of that conviction that you're not going
to get the card you just want our advice
on how to tell them to shut up
pretty much and how to stay on track
yeah yeah well number one sell the
friends that's an easy start right there
you know dave's always saying tell the
car i think we got to sell the friends
oh there we go sure you can't sell
people well in the words of ken coleman
you tell him to pound sand and kick
rocks yeah so here's what i would say
joseph so joseph is there anything
in their pitch to you that is tempting
you
anything about this tell me because
that's what i think you're getting at
you're like i need to tell them but then
i need to stay on track so what's
tempting you tell me about this double
points credit card whatever what is
what's tempting you
well the biggest thing that tempts me
out of everything is the fact that you
know
the whole issue with the credit score
because my brother brought up the fact
that you know when you buy a house or
when you're all right so joseph i'm
interrupting you because we only have a
few minutes a few seconds left george
tell them about the credit score so uh
i'll just steer you to this podcast
episode we did on the fine print called
the dirty truth behind your credit score
i want you and all your friends and your
brother and your mom all sit down and
listen to this because i'm telling you
i've lived without a score for many many
years i bought a house without a score
i've paid cash for cars you can live
without a score i want you to build
wealth not your credit score
that is going to be your long-term plan
to success my friend joseph you just
heard it from no score george that's
what they call me in high school
mostly because i did not score in any
sport ken we brought it back i'm glad
you clarified that
joseph here's the deal you know what you
want to do you want to know you know the
life you want to live just say thanks no
thanks i don't want to talk about you're
making me feel uncomfortable fake the
snowflake move
everybody takes care of the snowflake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
open phones triple 825-5225
joshua joins us up next in san diego
california joshua welcome to the show
hey thanks guys absolutely how come can
i help
hey so i'm 37 years old and i am getting
near the millionaire mark
working towards this should be there by
the end of this year way to go man and
thanks hey so my question is really on
the baby step seven
so you know my
my self-worth is mostly in real estate
um i moved from texas to california some
people say i reverse i'm integrated for
some people
and student necessity most of my
self-worth is in real estate
and now i'm at the point where you know
i want to you mean your net worth right
period yeah you keep saying it's
self-worth i was like oh my goodness i
gotta give this special you're worth so
much more
so um
you know my parents they're immigrants
and they said um the way they do things
is you know invest in cds and insurance
they're more traditional
and i want to talk to you guys to see
you know when i was in texas that was
more on retirement you know mutual funds
401k ras
but from here you know building out the
wealth from a different scale i want to
see you know are there different methods
of approaching this
there's different methods and there are
better methods i'll tell you that much
cds and insurance are not your path to
wealth
so your parents got sold to by some
sales people
at some point and they now believe that
and so i'm glad you're open to something
else because uh the way you're gonna
build wealth is partially how you've
been doing it which is
building up your uh your real estate
portfolio and you got a paid for house
are you close
um it's 60 equity but my texas house i
had to pay it off back then yeah cool
and then you moved to california you
took on a mortgage and you're working on
paying that off
i am it's going to take a while yeah
okay so what's your net worth today
about 9 15. awesome way to go man so uh
you're asking us how do i build wealth
the best way the right way
yeah i think california might be a
little different than other states
potentially well the way the path there
isn't any different it may look
different because of you know the
housing but you're going to pay this
house off you're going to invest just
like every other american
should invest and i want you investing
15 of your income into retirement
accounts like a 401k an ira do you have
um accounts like that available to you
i do yes okay
so until you pay off the house i want
you investing fifteen percent
once you have the house paid off you're
in baby step seven then the world is our
oyster we can increase that investing
you can save up and pay cash for real
estate but either way i want you
investing in mutual funds and index
funds
that's it got it
in real estate obviously
so those are going to be your best path
to wealth not cds not they're talking
about permanent life insurance and using
that as an investment we're not doing
that do you have a term life policy
i do yes okay great that's all you need
on the insurance side for as far as uh
life insurance goes
so as long as you're investing into good
growth stock mutual funds we recommend
diversity of diversifying across four
types
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international and if you do
that over a long period of time this is
exactly how i invest how dave ramsey
himself invests and you do that in your
401k we love roth it's the best option
do you have a roth option at
work not at work but personally yes so
you have a roth ira
i do yes okay and you're not above the
income limit to contribute to that
i might be my salary increased
quite a bit recently yeah good for you
man
so that may not be an option you can do
things like a back door roth and uh do
you have a financial advisor you're
working with currently
i do not
okay that is something i would recommend
to have that kind of coach in your
corner i've got one dave has one rachel
has one ken has one and this is someone
who's going to help you along the
journey
to help you understand what to do what
you're investing in they're not going to
make any decisions for you but they're
going to educate you so that you feel
confident in those decisions
that'll be great yes so you can jump on
ramseysolutions.com and click on trusted
pros and they're called smart vester
pros we have them in your area you can
connect with one and they're going to
help you figure out what that looks like
for you with your income and your state
all of those things but man you're doing
so well 37 years old almost a
millionaire ken yeah i like this very
exciting stuff i love it thanks for the
call joshua dennis joins us up next in
beaver dam wisconsin that might be my
favorite city name yet dennis welcome to
the show
thank you how can we help
i'm 21 years old and i'm looking at
going into college
paid mostly by work and i was wondering
if that's a good idea with uh recently
just purchasing a vehicle and so having
rent to pay for
all my other bills
so what's the question in there should
you keep working
while in school
no
the question is do i push out college uh
later on after i've got money saved up
for
my life exp uh expenses but you said
they're paying for it
correct so you're paying for it in full
so how does that increase any expenses
you have
because i would have to pay uh i would
not be making any income during this oh
you'd have to stop okay so so your
company is going to pay for your tuition
but you would be a full-time student so
not any income but they are paying
tuition
correct um
so what have you determined your how
long will you be in school is it a
traditional four-year path or shorter
it's a two-year path okay so if you run
the numbers on what your living expenses
will be
yep it's going to be around 1500 bucks a
month and how much do you have saved
towards that goal
about 2 000
okay what's the total number i guess
what i mean what's the total number over
that two year period that you need to
save up
i have not done the math about that yet
start there right so
however many months you're not going to
be in school 12 months a year true or
false
so
okay
false you're going to be in school 12
months a year
oh my bad my dad okay sure i'm not going
to be in the store that's right so let's
just say you're in school for nine
months so you got three months where you
can work i don't know if that company
that you're working for will pay you to
work during that time but you can go
make money somewhere else because you're
not in school true or false
true true excellent so you start to take
what my living expenses are but i'm
going to be working during the three
months you just got to play this all out
so now you know the number that you need
to save up
um
and
what's the plan after you get the
two-year
education is it a promotion with your
current company
correct i'll be a full-time diesel
technician
oh fantastic now are you on the strings
for anything are they you have to sign a
contract saying you'll work there for a
certain period of time
two years yep good okay and you're and
you're all in on that right you're not
gonna get one year into this to start
resenting the fact that you gotta commit
to this like this is a joyful commitment
because they're paying for your
education
yep i i'm loving this company so i'm not
i'm not too afraid of that fantastic
okay how much debt do you have
uh about six thousand dollars on my
truck but that's about it
okay because my it sounds like you're
concerned that you're not gonna be able
to afford your expenses and that's
partially due to your payment on the
truck right
correct what would the truck sell for
today um i i currently have a lean
through the bank
so you can't sell it
correct
well how long would it take you to pay
off the truck
um you went after it with everything you
got
around this december oh i'm wondering
can you pay the truck off and then start
school
yeah that's a possibility i could just
push school out later i think that's
going to take away some of the stress
that you're feeling about losing this
income while being in school what's the
truck payment
it's 500 bucks a month yeah but you
still got to have income to pay for your
living expenses so you still got to run
that exercise out right george yes
but i think that extra 500 bucks a month
that you can help is going to help
avoid a lot of stress and anxiety
yep so i talk to your company and say
hey here's the deal i really appreciate
you putting me through school i want to
wait until my truck's paid off so that i
can afford my living expenses here's my
plan and just be clear about it with
them yep and double triple check what
you think you're going to need
to live comfortably during that time you
know what i mean you got to really think
through it you know me stuck eating
ramen noodles that entire time now
although i ate my fair share of ramen
noodles during college oh boy and it
shows ken it shows
you're very frail thank you george well
hey dennis thanks for the call man that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to ken coleman my
co-host all the folks in the booth and
you america thanks for listening we'll
be back with you before you know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well
i'm george campbell joined today by ken
coleman and we are taking your calls
america the number to call is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five
lenore kicks us off in austin texas
lenore welcome to the show
hi did we get the name right thank you
yes you do thanks for taking my call
happy to take it how can we help
well um
i've been listening to this show for
quite a while and been wanting to call
and today i was
extremely motivated to call because
something came up and i've been wanting
to call on speak regarding this topic
my company i just found out today that i
was just
let go
july 22nd and
i've been with my company for about full
23 years or so oh my goodness and i'm so
sorry it's an investment company yeah i
kind of expected it i'll tell you why
but my main question is
i just want to
prior to this happening for the last
couple of years i've kind of wanted to
do something different for the last part
of my
career working life
i'm 57
and
i just wanted to
i don't want to stop working right now
because i enjoy working but i want to do
something that
is something that's coming from my
spirit that i enjoy and not just
necessarily my head and what is it an
investment company
what is that right now i think you i
think you know or you've wondered about
it enough give me give me a description
of it don't worry about how pretty it
sounds
well i'm not i actually
um
i know what i used to want to do but i
don't think i'm what was that you go
through all that right now and uh
counseling or psychology but i really
don't think i'm prepared to want to go
back to school for that sure um
i
was interested in
getting my real estate license something
that i could work from home
and
do well because i
know how to talk to people i have
excellent customer service i work in an
investment company and i actually place
trades all day and deal with
other dealers back office i do not talk
to clients or shareholders
and we just talk money and trades and
this and that and
i'm just kind of tired of it anyway sure
but um
i
that this company recently
since last december
uh required us to get the covet vaccine
and for my own reasons i did not want it
and
it's um
a commitment uh where i do trust god and
i know he's got something for me but
uh they allowed us to submit an
exemption request twice
and it was not approved okay so they did
notify me today so
lenora we're sorry about that i'm glad
that you had at least some kind of
warning so it's not as shocking
right but listen you've been with this
these folks a long time and i think the
one thing i want to encourage your heart
on is that
um
you haven't lost your value
and you have developed over the 23 years
with this company
and whatever work you did before you've
developed
some very valuable experience and you
certainly have developed some skills
and so what your exercise is right now
is i think that there are some really
clear clues
in the fact that a long time ago you
were interested in psychology or
counseling or therapy
and so i totally understand at this
stage in your life you don't want to go
to the schooling that's necessary for
that but it doesn't mean that you are
completely uh
abandoning
what's behind that and you take the
uh previous desire to maybe do some form
of counseling or psychology type work
and you combine it with the fact that
you just said you know what i do all day
is pretty much numbers and i'm not
customer facing i'm not dealing with
people and you you combine the fact that
you mentioned real estate which would
allow you to have flexibility of course
working from home but this is the theme
that is emerging in all of these things
is people
you love working with people and in the
next season the final work season of
your life you want to work with people
is that true
correct i do and i also
want i want to work with people and what
motivates me too to work at least 10
to even 15 more years because great
i'm young i consider my question but
i really want to put more towards my
retirement as well because i i don't
have much left on my home good so here's
what i want you to focus on okay and i'm
going to give you my get clear career
assessment
um
at the end of our call and i want you to
take it's about a 20-minute assessment
it's going to allow you to see
what you're most talented at doing and
none of this should be a big surprise
but it will confirm for you
this is where most of my talent is and i
think you're probably going to score
high on people talents so that's what
you do best and it's going to help you
see the type of work that you love and i
think it's going to be very
people-focused type work we call that
passion and the last piece is what
motivates you when you do work
uh and we call that mission what
missional results and for you i bet
you're gonna score high on service and
influence okay so i'm gonna give you
that to take on your own time but here's
the exercise even when you get your
purpose statement that this uh
assessment will spit out for you
i want you to look at it as a high level
job description and you're looking in on
who are the people i most want to help
so if we look at real estate i want to
help new home buyers or people that are
looking to uh
level up in their home purchase their
their their their their place of living
and it has memories and it has safety
and it has all these things tied to it
if that's the problem you want to help
people solve great but if there's
another problem that you want to help
people solve that pulls and tugs at your
heart more than anything else you've got
to pay attention to that and you go okay
now where in the workplace in the
marketplace of jobs can i help the
people i most want to help solve the
problem that they have with the solution
that i can get connected to and fired up
so i just want to encourage you on the
process
that's why i asked that question what
have you wondered about who are the
people you most want to help so i'm
going to put you on the spot if you
don't have an answer that's fine we'll
give you the assessment and it's going
to come clear but i want you to just
don't think for a moment i want you just
to react you willing to do that
i want one right from the top of your
heart here's what i want to know forget
about qualifications or money for the
moment
who are the people you would most like
to spend the next 10 to 15 years of your
working life helping who are the people
what pops in your mind right now
well i'm while you were talking and i
thought about this before is over the
experience that i've had and things that
i've learned
and what i'm going through
i would really love to help people that
are in my or not just in my world but
uh not to be afraid of money and to know
how to
um
to have financial peace
to have financial peace that's what you
want to help people with so here's the
deal take the get clear career
assessment hang online we're going to
give it to you and let's see if your
purpose statement aligns with that i
think it's going to absolutely and then
where in the marketplace do i work for
smart investor pro since i'm familiar
with ramsey solutions and i am
contributing to financial peace that's
just one idea maybe your financial coach
take the test get really clear on who
you want to help and why and then we
figure out where can i do that hang on
the line awesome pickup will get you the
get clear assessment thank you so much
for the call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by ken coleman
reminder for you folks you can come by
and visit us here at the ramsey
solutions headquarters me and ken were
just out there saying hi to the nice
people and getting away from a young
gentleman out there thank you sir uh
we're just south of nashville tennessee
we've got free baked goods coffee it's a
whole visitor center experience there's
like a timeline wall museum you can
check out you get a free mug on your way
out it's bring the whole family ken yeah
and there's a fun little doll it's the
dancing george and uh we give that away
to kids under the age of 10. so that's
all again someone's gonna show up asking
for the the george doll and we're gonna
have to let him down and say that
doesn't exist why are you so worried no
one wants to see a dancing george you
could be proud when i say that people
think that's serious you'd be surprised
there's a niche audience that
would request that okay folks i'm
kidding uh having fun today there is no
dancing george doll although george uh
when you come out uh we come out we come
out in the lobby and say hi to folks
during breaks george will dance for you
apparently i've been told i'm a tiny
dancer
yeah you are there you go
all right open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
donny joins us up next in boston donny
welcome to the show how's it going
hey man it's going good thanks for
having me on i appreciate you guys
taking my fault sure happy to take it
what's going on
so
you know i just started listening to the
show i'd say in like the last two months
or so
my parents church back home in georgia
they've gotten real big with
the financial piece
university yeah so they've been doing a
lot of that i know my parents have done
classes but i never really
paid any attention and
fast forward now i've kind of i've
gotten a job
after college i was supposed to start
law school
uh it went virtual so i kind of said
about that i have a travel job that i do
and i've been doing for about a year now
and i'm in a situation where
they pay for my housing and my
transportation and pretty much my cost
of living is almost at zero wow other
than a car payment so what i'm trying to
figure out is how can i take advantage
of you know the current state of our
economy and the downturn so that a year
from now and you know even five years
from now and hopefully i'm you know
starting a family and i'm married that i
look back and appreciate
you know what i did now i love it so how
old are you
25 25 and what's your income
um it's like between 70 and 80. wow love
it and that's on top of most of your
expenses being covered
yup so they um you know they pretty much
just put me like an airbnb because the
nature of the work is
a travel sales job
uh it's politics so don't hate me for it
um
no hate here well wait a second now
donny i used to be in politics are you
working on campaigns or are you working
for a pack and you're just kind of
moving around from place to place so
submit sure both essentially good yeah i
totally know what that i that's what i
did when i was in my early 20s
absolutely so we don't hate you how
about that okay cool cool yeah you're
fine i started in bc where i was under
the law school yeah kind of said i don't
want to do that tapped into my network i
started in politics and i was a
sophomore in high school and it just
kind of tapped into my uh network and
it's honestly it's been a huge blessing
the position
man that's fantastic so how much debt do
you have
uh zero well you just said you had a car
payment
oh yeah yeah okay well then you're hold
on donny you're already lying to me
he's new to the show he didn't pay
attention to the financial peace classes
in his church
yeah yeah see that's what i'm calling i
got your back is there any other debt
that you want to let me know about
donnie while we're being honest no yeah
just by car payment 600 dollars a month
and it comes out automatically and i
paid it ahead three months so i try to
stay three months ahead of that just
because you know the nature of this
you know with politics and stuff i just
try to you know keep myself ahead of any
calls to that so with traveling are you
taking the car with you are you flying
and then getting a rental car to get
around so i i take the car with me i got
a dog so it makes it a lot easier for me
to get around with her okay what's
what's left on the loan for the car
18 000 okay what's the car worth
27.
oh that's a good day well here's the
deal you called not asking about any of
this you called asking about how you can
be taking advantage of the market and
saving and investing
and your number one wealth building tool
is your income that's 70 80 000
and right now you're sending 600
of your take-home pay to a lender every
single month
and so with our plan here's how we like
to put it we want you to become debt
free with a fully funded emergency fund
before we ever start investing
so the question is how quickly can you
get there
do you have any money saved in the bank
yeah so i mean i could almost turn my
car off completely i'd sell the car but
i'm always very aggressive on that yeah
for a 25 year old who's traveling around
the country i mean dog i mean come on
man just could sell i'd sell it and i'd
buy a ten thousand dollar car nine
thousand you're gonna make nine grand if
you sell it
no i know and the truth is i bought it
when i was in nova because i thought i'd
be in the dc area and then it's just
been such a it's been a whirlwind since
sell the car hey sell the car you're
immediately debt free you get a decent
car you're young you're making really
good money and it's a transition car
until you save up man you can get ahead
as a young guy uh because are you
planning to just keep moving from uh
campaign to campaign
for a while no
what's your plan honestly
so politically the three year plan is to
go back to dc and either you know sooner
than later get back into law school
which doesn't really that's not really
where my heart's at don't go to law
school don't go to law school
sorry george so you riled ken up about
his career that's why i'm pausing i want
to make sure we give him the financial
advice and finish that and then i want
to talk about this law degree i'm going
to save you a lot of money on the other
side the car is not killing you i mean
based on your income it's okay if you
want to aggressively pay it off but you
told me you're way more excited about
saving and investing and so yeah that
tells me you don't really care about
having a 30 000 car right now so let's
sell it let's get something cheaper so
that we can begin investing you said you
had savings i still want you to get
three to six months of expenses which
right now you don't have much which is
great but still get six months of
expenses saved up and then begin
investing 15 percent of your income into
great retirement accounts into mutual
funds things of that nature not stocks
and crypto yeah and and done yeah so
i've stayed away from crypto um all my
friends got into the hyatt and they
tried to convince me all your friends
are broke now aren't they
well i don't want to say that fiona
might be listening but i'm happy i
didn't do it good for you now donnie
let's let's skip law school for a moment
what's the long-term play for you
where do you want to be in 20 years i
want to be president one day but i mean
everybody says that no but
donny you're talking to the right guy i
mean the one day you call into the show
you get me because dave and and
everybody else doesn't care dave would
get this look on his face like he has
indigestion and i actually get what
you're talking about and so here's the
day you want to run here's the deal you
want to run for office
sure the end of the road would be
president but the deal is you want to
serve
your country as an elected official and
i get that that was the path for me when
i came out of high school and then it
changed for me but
here's the deal
you don't need a law degree to become an
elected official in fact that was the i
will tell you that was the plan that was
kind of the the way to do it
30 years ago but the political landscape
has changed you know that you don't need
a law degree that you don't want
and that's another chance to go into
debt
i thought about being an entrepreneur
like i have a lot of interest in opening
a brewery at a boy here's what i think
you ought to do i think you ought to ask
yourself
i know long term that you want to run
for office but until that timing is
right
what kind of work would you really enjoy
doing and if it's business small
business entrepreneur can i just tell
you that's going to set you up to be a
much more attractive candidate than
being a lawyer you're a guy who pays
attention to polls you know this go look
and i'm not knocking lawyers i get some
good friends who are lawyers but go look
at what the perception is of lawyers
among the american people i'm telling
you a small business person who creates
jobs and who uh earns something by the
skin of their teeth the sweat of their
proud whole sweater their breath that's
what attracts people so
uh
don't go law school please you don't
need it to run for us
i think i'm sold i've been i've been
having that same thought process that
you know being an entrepreneur as a job
creator yeah people tend to like you a
lot more if you're you know selling them
beer than they would you know if you're
just some you know guy in a suit that's
right that's how sam adams did it right
yeah started a brewery george with the
president
guys i'm from boston it was a joke well
okay yeah but hey
congressman coleman's got a ring to it
oh stop it it's got a ring that's all
i'm saying no it doesn't it sounds awful
okay sounds terrible you're in the right
i'm a man of the people but i don't need
to get anybody to vote for me to do that
just come on over to the ken cole you've
got my vote it's the only one that
counts thank you hey more coming up this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
i'm george campbell next to me is ken
coleman this is the ramsay show open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five
logan joins us up next from lexington
kentucky logan welcome to the show
hey gentlemen how's it going great how
are you
great man doing well how going on so
just a quick question yeah just a quick
question so
i currently have a lease uh it's a 2019
camry
um it's due
in august is when i have to return it uh
the way that the market's going right
now obviously i've been looking at kelly
blue book
um i think trade in is about 27 29 and
private is about 29 to 31.
um my wife and i just had our first
uh child he's about a week and a half
old at this point
all right i appreciate it yeah man
listen you are remarkably coherent given
the fact that you have a one week old
i'd be exhausted i wouldn't know how to
sell i would have speaking make a phone
call yeah very good good for you
yeah good man good man
so you're looking at your options
what's your question
following anything ramsay related at all
but we paid off about 85 000 in student
loans in a year way to go huh um
yeah yeah it was tough but we did it
good and now we're debt-free
just seeing if it's worth it should i
just turn the car back in or should we
buy it out
and
what would it cost to buy it
yeah it's going for about 20 000 right
now is what i owe on it okay
and you can make 31.
i think so um it's it feels about right
for a 2019 camry
yeah it's pretty decked out so it's
pretty sweet i hate to get rid of it but
doesn't fit a car seat how much money do
you have
so that's the next question so we have
about 20 000 in just the bank and then
we have about 24 000 in a brokerage
account which used to be 35 so selling
that
would be tough since the market's so low
and that's kind of why i'm trying to get
some advice um
so you would have zero dollars in the
bank
if you bought this car outright
yeah so my wife and i make pretty decent
money we
have before tax we're about 210 000 a
year awesome and since it's due in
august i'm thinking we can probably
save up quite a bit until then okay
again
all right so i want to this is relevant
george i'm i'm interjecting here uh
because between the two of us i'm the
one with kids fair sorry george that's
all right uh
you can fit a car seat you got one
little dude you can fit a car seat
comfortably in a camry dude i'm not
trying to bring some judgment on you i'm
just trying to introduce that fact of
this conversation because it does figure
into what you would do
this idea that once we have a kid we
gotta have a minivan we gotta have an
suv total garbage uh one kid fits
beautifully in a camry all right
now that i've interjected that sure
the car is very reasonable compared to
your income so if you're good with it
i'd buy it out and keep the car and try
to have a few thousand dollars as kind
of your starter emergency fund when you
do that and then let's be about the
business of saving up a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months
and then we invest so if you're doing
any investing right now just pause that
until we're in a better spot financially
gotcha do you like the car
forget the car seat issue that i just
jumped all over
do you like the camry
yeah no we definitely love the car um
what's your life
so she has a prius
yeah i get it is she wanting a uh
certain vehicle
we're thinking about maybe getting a
rav4 or something a little bit bigger
that's what we're thinking but i got to
tell you the rav4 is not bigger
it's up higher it may be of a different
chassis george i'll explain what that
means later oh he's not not expecting
chassis to be brought into the show i
watch nascar all right don't judge me
okay do you understand what i'm saying
logan like i just want you guys to make
the right financial decision
you know and not to be swayed by an
emotion that a rav4 is somehow more
equipped for a baby than a camry it's
not
got it so i guess you guys would
recommend just buying out the car or
getting rid of it in general and just
saving the 20 that we have on hand
yeah i mean you get to decide but i mean
my worst case you you do the buy out and
then you sell it and make 10 grand yeah
and that gives you some money towards
the next one
gotcha and the point is if you could
afford is the rav4 more expensive than
what you got now
a newer one yes yeah that's what i'm
leaning towards i'm not just for all the
rav4 lovers out there i have no problem
with the rav4 but it's like you got
enough car for the season that you're
right before cancel culture is coming
for you
oh i know i'm gonna get hammered online
for that logan you guys make a great
income i would be about the business of
stacking up as much cash as possible
temporarily getting out of this lease
yeah and then we can make a wise
decision yeah from a place of peace then
when you get three kids like we had then
i had to get something that would fit
three kids but man i'd stick two kids
back there
back in the day ken you know it was a
different time i can throw goals fishing
at each other huh kids fit in any car
back in the day don't even start i grew
up
when when they're what you sat in the
front seat gosh i missed it and he
didn't have a seat belt on it if dad had
to hammer the brakes he did one of these
numbers for our listening audience it's
a nice full extension of the left hand
please don't slap me right into the
chest and if that didn't work you went
headfirst into some legitimate steel the
1950s were a different time ken i know i
hate to take us back to nostalgia but
the point is the camry's enough car and
it gets you ahead financially fair i
need to spend money on a cute little
rav4
next up david joins us in houston texas
david welcome to the show
hey guys glad to be on the show yeah
great to have you what's going on
uh so i had a kind particular situation
where i got the opportunity to assume a
loan on a house
for 156 000
at an interest rate that's awesome and
now i'm deciding whether or not i should
just move into the house and live in it
or sell it off
so what do you mean you're assuming the
loan what's the situation
so a family member is moving away
doesn't want to put it on the market
doesn't want to deal with it anymore and
so they were like if you just want to
take over the loan with the loan company
you can and
effectively what happens is all of the
debt just transfers to me so she's got
26 years left on the lonely
at a 2.25
interest rate
but you would be the owner of the
property
correct where do you live now
uh well i live in san antonio i'm just
renting now so i'm deciding whether or
not and it's just down the road for me
it's not a much of a move it's just a
difference of owning versus currently
i'm renting
and what's the
what's the mortgage payment compared to
what you're paying in rent
uh so currently i'm paying 600 on rent
if i was to pay with mortgage and the
interest rate it's a little bit more
it's about 650.
so what's your income
uh
so our household income is like 97 000
okay
so what's the house worth
uh so i just had an appraised
uh with the intent of removing pmi and
then appraised for 215. so my question
is should i just take the raw equity i
have throw it back off to someone else
and move on with my life with 50 30 you
know 50 000 free dollars or should i
move it
well
and you're sure there's not going to be
any i mean wouldn't you have capital
gains on that
uh i i would have capital gains on that
but if i turn 31 it i can roll it into a
you know a newer house or something more
but that would have to be an investment
property
pardon me then yeah they would have to
pay capital gains yeah even till i
assume that i'd lose 25 30
still walk away with 20 30 000. all
right so okay so he's laid it out
beautifully george so now i think it
comes down to where were you uh
thinking about housing
uh were you planning to rent for a while
or were you thinking i want to buy at
some point prior to this situation
coming in out of the sky well a rent is
so cheap that i just plan on kind of
running that for the next you know while
while i save up money and then
eventually buy a house with cash but
well i think that that plays into it
i would just look into all the details
that feels a little
fishy for them to just hand this over to
you instead of them selling it and
keeping the profit
well it's a situation where they bought
it with her husband and there's some bad
mojo so they just want to wipe wash
their hands of it essentially which is
why they're just like yeah i don't think
it's fishy
spoke with a lawyer and whatnot so okay
yeah i just want to make sure you got
your keys crossed your eyes dotted there
talk to tax pros talk to real estate
agents just make sure you're walking
into this slowly with wisdom and not
impulsively to try to make a quick buck
that's what i want
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell
co-hosting today ken coleman this is the
ramsey show the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we can help you with
all of the crossroads you're dealing
with in life whether it's with your
career your money
your life we are here for you america
garrett joins us up next in raleigh
north carolina garrett welcome to the
show
hey gentlemen thank you guys for taking
my call today absolutely how can we help
so just have a really quick question um
so right now me and my wife we both
we both i've graduated college she's
actually in her doctorate program at
school and we have about seventy five
thousand dollars in student loans
between the both of us and we're just
trying to kind of figure out what we
need to do here okay
so um
how many loans is this across
uh so
so it's between two it's so it comes at
the same company both of them do and
it's just it's like a long kind of thing
bound together so there's like five
inside of each one so mine's 20 thousand
dollars hers right now is 52. okay
so uh we recommend using the debt
snowball method to pay off those debts
which is listing them all smallest to
largest and just ignore the interest
rate on all of them because we want you
to make progress really fast so what's
the smallest loan
so actually let me ask you this question
very quickly so she like i said she's
still in school so we're still
technically
accruing
some uh
what would it take to cash flow the rest
of school
about 45 000 a year
okay what's your income
86 000. okay is that just you or she
working as well while she's doing the
doctorate program
it is just me okay
cool so 86 000 and it would take 45 to
cash flow how is that just one year she
has left
two
two years and it's 45 a year yes
yes so she's going to go 90 000 more
into debt to get this
doctorate
well we pay we already do pay 15 out of
out of pocket each year to 15 grand out
of pocket so it would be it'd be an
acquiring of 20 so it would be about 41
000
41 000 on top of the 75
yes okay well right now you're going to
have a hard time making progress while
we're digging the hole even deeper
i understand that and so my goal would
be to stop the bleeding here and try to
cash flow as much as possible
because she's not having to pay on her
student loans while she's in school
right
correct okay
so i mean once she's out of school how
much is she going to be making what kind
of work will she be getting into
it'll be the medical field we're
probably going to be looking at
somewhere between 80 to 120.
okay on top of your 86
yes
okay so then it becomes well making 200
grand how quickly are we going to pay
off 110
that would be when you were planning on
one year when it comes to that we're
just kind of wanting to see what we
probably should be doing right now
right now your best bet is to take out
as little debt as possible hopefully
nothing but it sounds like that's not an
option for you and she's not going to
pause the program
yeah no we're definitely not going to
pause the program
we're already this invested into it
sunk cost fallacy okay well what do you
think can you talk to people a lot who
are getting education and paying for it
and trying to help them navigate the
financial side well i mean you know look
i don't know that i could add a whole
lot to this because she's committed to
this and and it's it's it's happening
and so the reality is is they don't have
the financial wherewithal to actually
cash flow this unless she presses pause
is that fair garrett
yes yeah are there any scholarships
grants available that she could be
applying for
now
what's happening here garrett is is that
you know i i'm like i would press pause
if it were me and i would cash flow
that's what i would do
um because i at the end of the day you
look at the unbelievable debt burden
that you guys are going to walk away
with and she's going to come into this
new path all excited about it but the
reality is we know what the emotional
grind is like because you're calling
today because you want to get out of it
and so you're assuming that and
this is not popular and i'm not
suggesting that you tell her that i said
this
but but that's what i would do i would
press pause because the doctorate is
still going to be there
and i would cash flow the rest of it and
not take out the debt that that's me
because i know what the work economy
looks like and i know that she can go do
something and and you guys could double
your income theoretically and and get to
a point where you can walk into that
doctorate and finish it out
with cash is that going to delay
the uh the destination absolutely it is
but that's something that i would do
because i think the trade-off
is so much better it's agonizing waiting
but it is
so depressing
getting out and wanting to be all
excited about this work and feel like
everything you're doing is going to pay
it off and so it's a different mindset
both are hard
but one
is so much more fulfilling and it's so
much more fulfilling when you don't have
that debt does that make sense
it makes perfect sense what what other
debt do you guys have garrett
none that's it it's only that okay so
remind me what the total would be if you
don't do what i said and pause what's
the total debt burden coming out
sounds like it's about 116.
say
41.116 okay okay yeah it'd be right
around there
yes and also i kind of want to bring
this up also so we we we do have a good
established emergency fund um i know you
we probably need to dwindle it down to
about a thousand but there's about 35
000 in that whoa and there's an
additional
yeah dude this debt is the emergency my
retirement
yeah and you're investing too and
yes my retirement is also an additional
35 so wait a second wait a second now we
don't have to press pause for very long
what if if you pay it off we go down to
a thousand you take 34 yep you cash flow
the next year you get about the business
you stop investing which is going to
free up cash flow from your income and
we be about the business of cash flowing
the final amount
could that get you guys without adding
any more debt could that get her her
doctorate
yes i think it was good
that would be my plan that's an option
it's the best option but
i'm sorry you called us and asked for
our opinion it's worth what you paid for
it what is the so yeah you would do that
as opposed to pressing pause on the
doctoral program and paying off the debt
we're not pausing it i'm going you got
35 sitting now i'm not touching
retirement don't touch that but i would
pause retirement until you're completely
dead i think those are two really good
options i'll go with george's is the
best option you know
you know because it here's the thing
you're feeling pretty comfortable with
35 000 in the bank but the truth is the
house is on fire
we're walking out of this thing with six
figures in debt i'm gonna tell you
something folks you come out of school i
don't care what your fancy doctorate is
i don't care how fancy your freaking
school is and you come into the
marketplace you've been desiring to do
this work
and you come home after the first two
weeks four weeks six weeks and you
realize how much your debt
repayment is it is so stifling oh
absolutely so garrett here's what i'm
gonna do for you austin's gonna pick up
we're gonna get you a code to use to
watch borrowed future the documentary i
want you to sit down with your wife make
it a date night have a nice meal and
watch this 88 minute documentary that we
released last fall and i think it's
gonna get you closer to the option i
recommended which is let's stop the
bleeding let's not go further into debt
so we can be saddled when she gets this
new job and goes wait wait i'm making
great money where's it all going
oh it's going to navient and maximus and
sally may and making them rich instead
of helping us build wealth and so i'm
looking for your long-term future versus
your short-term you know comfort that's
what this is all about and i think if
you do this plan you liquidate most of
that savings except for a thousand
dollars and you feel that fire under
your belly going this doesn't feel safe
it shouldn't
i want you to get rid of this debt so
that you guys can live the lives you
were meant to live i like that you use
the word saddled saddled i don't think
it's used enough well i i gotta tell you
uh you imagine what a horse feels like
and i'm i'm not mr animal rights
activist but honestly
you know they just want to eat they want
to graze and you slap a saddle on them
and then you throw your
body into that saddle and you're
carrying a person around like oh here we
go so in this situation you're the horse
and navi and sally may are the saddle on
your back they're on your back you're
dragging them to work with you every day
and on the way back home i think it's a
really good uh i like that you use
saddle because i started thinking about
it i always feel for the trail horse you
know these guys they've been in it a
long time what don't you know about ken
you know a lot about sports horses
politics we're in dangerous territory
here talking about horses yeah you know
can i go oh i got canceled by horse
culture because i told a caller to sell
a horse because she was very broke
and i wish i'd had been on with you that
day because they said here's what they
said it's like selling a child i went no
that's cool trafficking that's illegal
people sell horses all the time yeah
they do so don't come at me with that
logic yeah i mean
people make big money breeding these
horses and selling all kinds of things
around horses that's right george you're
a good and decent man
thank you tell you thank you
take that all the way to the bank
america yeah that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books i'm george
campbell that's ken coleman appreciate
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show afloat and you america we
appreciate you listening in
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by ken coleman and we are taking your
calls the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's talk
about your work your life your money
many of you at a crossroads when it
comes to your career right now figuring
out where to go i think we want to move
we're remote we just got laid off
there's a hot job market what do we do
i'm not doing the things that i want to
be doing and ken you're taking so many
calls on your show of people switching
and you're helping them navigate it yeah
it's happening you know people saying
hey i certainly want to jump in on this
you know roller coaster ride where
people are leveling up big time we're
seeing right now an average of a 14
increase in salary
when people change jobs
and and let's point this out you want to
know what a major driver of the
inflation is
increase in wages
so certainly moving
to another company can
give you a big boost in income but we
want to make sure that we're moving
not just for the paycheck but we're
going okay i'm moving to get on the
right seat
on the right bus
because if we can do that
and of course the income is there the
increase is there rather now we're
setting ourselves up for just continual
growth and so that's what we focus on
the ken coleman show what were you
created to do all of us have a unique
combination of talent what we do best
passion
work we love
and a sense of mission
uh results that motivate us and so when
we can get all three of those unique
elements in alignment good things happen
so that's what we do we'd love to help
some people out today yeah you can use
that income to do the baby steps which
is what we preach here on the show so
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five rob joins us
first in chattanooga rob welcome to the
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
so this question is mainly for ken but
george i love your input um i love my
company that i work for i love my bosses
i've got three
bosses up the line that are you know
amazing but as i've gone further into my
career i've noticed that
more of what i'm doing i'm you know the
bad guy to our clients when things are
good i don't have to say much but it's
when things are bad that i have to speak
up and
you know starting to wonder if that's
for me because i'm a pretty happy go
lucky upbeat guy and i don't like being
the bearer of bad news
tell me a little bit more about the role
what do you mean by when things go wrong
i have to be the bad guy to our clients
so we're the consultant for we're a
consultant engineer and we work for
clients that hire contractors to do work
and so when the contractors aren't doing
it correctly we turn around and tell the
clients that hey this is what's going
wrong here and the contractor typically
has push back or looks at us or argues
with us like we don't know what we're
talking about and it's typically
frustrating
and it sounds like it's draining to you
yeah yeah it definitely is yeah
and uh
you have you been in that role the
entire time you've been with this
company or is this something that you
kind of evolved into
well i've evolved into it i've had the
same role but i've been given a lot more
responsibility in the last year and i
really noticed this over the last three
months on two of the jobs where things
are you know
not going according to plan and
we have to bring it up yeah and and and
it's to the point where you go i don't i
don't think i can keep doing this is
that is that fair
i can do it i don't have a problem doing
it it's just no that's not true i'm not
a you do you do have a problem doing it
and that's not bad i'm trying to free
you here it drains you so much that you
sit there and you wonder how much longer
or i know you can do it but that it's
not a function of
of of technically doing it it's just how
much longer emotionally can you there's
a sense of dread every time you have to
go and deal with one of these am i right
oh yeah you're right okay then so
that's eventually going to turn into
resentment
i don't know how long
because you're a good guy with a lot of
character but i'm telling you
if you don't resolve this and what i
mean by resolve is you got to talk to
your leaders you got a great
relationship you said you love your
three bosses you love the company you
gotta go you know what this is dragging
me down and here's how it's affecting me
and
and and if i if we don't resolve it it's
gonna turn into something negative none
of us want that and i think i can add
greater value somewhere else and and i
think the conversation has to be one
that is you know what i realized this
about myself
when i have to deliver bad news
it drains me
it is not who i am
and uh and so i'm not at my best when
i'm doing this type of work for the
company
do you understand what i'm saying so far
absolutely now let me flip this
there are some people i'll raise my hand
just for example purposes that i have no
problem with confrontation
and and this is a form of confrontation
and and it drains you and it energizes
other people would you agree with that
rob you think of people in your life you
know that doing what you have to do that
drains you they could do it not it
doesn't even doesn't even make them
blink
oh yeah absolutely all right that's the
guy so as a leader
they need to know that that they're
gonna be better at it it's gonna
actually go smoother
it's going to be more effective when
this
work has to be done if we put somebody
in that
seat
who eats it for breakfast
makes sense
yes yes it does do you know of somebody
in the company because i want you to
come to this conversation with solutions
do you know somebody that you think
would probably enjoy doing it and
probably has the know-how and whatever
the other elements are to be able to do
it effectively
um well well i mean i can do it
effectively but i the problem is we're
our area our office is smaller so
there's not a whole lot of people here
i'm doing kind of many tests so they
might have to backfill for that position
if you
moved correct okay
is there some but but my point is what
if you did how much of of a percentage
is this type of draining work of your
overall work how much
um
30
40
it's pretty high man
so i i here's what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to help you get to the point i'm
trying to help you with a solution right
now but let me back up because i think
you can figure out the solution
you will resent this
job
and resent the company and resent
everybody else if you don't solve this
40
of your work
doing something that drains you is a
recipe for
discouragement despondency
depression i'm not trying to scare you
i'm just going
yeah it's the way we're wired bro you
know we're not wired to do something
that drains us we're wired to do
something that
uh fuels us
so
you gotta come to your leadership with a
solution
okay
so i'd be looking around the company
going hey i really love what that guy
does if i could do that every day man
that would fire me up or or rob it's hey
i'm gonna keep doing the 60
that i that i
already do
but i'm gonna carve off this 30 percent
to somebody else who's better at it it
doesn't drain them and i'll pick up
another 30 40 that adds value to the
company and something that i enjoy
that's the solution formula and then
they see you winning doing the other
part and they go man he should be doing
that full time he's so good at that it
lights him up
so i like that plan rob and it'll get
there it'll be take some conversations
with your leaders may not happen
tomorrow but you got to take steps uh
let's do this hey rob hang on the line
we're going to give you a get clear
assessment that's going to help you
further clarify and communicate how you
need to get in your sweet spot with this
company this will be a great tool as you
go through this thanks for the call
[Music]
[Music]
so many of our calls on the show lately
have been about fallout from the
pandemic rising inflation questions
about a recession
more than ever people need hope with
their finances and maybe you're feeling
that way too and that's why you need to
check out financial peace university
this is not your dad's version of fpu we
just did a massive update to our biggest
money course and it's still our proven
money principles but refreshed for what
you're facing today you're going to hear
from dave and rachel cruz of course but
we've just added dr john dolone and
myself and we're bringing some fresh
insights to show you new ways to look at
money so if you're feeling scared or
overwhelmed know that you're not alone
there's a lot going on these days you
just can't control but you can take
control of your money and ease your
money stress with financial peace
university and we're going to show you
how you can start fpu for free and check
out all of this new content by going to
ramseysolutions.com
that's ramsey solutions.com
fpu
i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman today this is the ramsey show
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five dylan joins
us up next in erie pennsylvania dylan
welcome to the show
how are you guys great how can we help
[Music]
you broke up on us dylan can you get
your phone uh to a good place
yeah can you hear me that's better let's
try that
okay
um
hey dylan you might need to turn the
microwave off something's interfering
there
please tell me he's near a microwave
that would make me happy hey we'll put
you on the line we'll see if austin gets
you some good he enjoyed it he got the
idea well we'll try it in just a moment
we're gonna go to brandon in phoenix
instead brandon welcome to the show
hey how are you guys great what's going
on i got asked if i wanted to apply for
a position um with my company as
operations manager up in a new facility
in marysville washington that's about an
hour north of seattle
i currently make 80 000 here
um and i'll be asking for
130 and would take nothing less than 120
up there
um
as far as career-wise it would be a huge
move the facility i'm in now is
probably the second to um smallest
facility in the company that one is the
third largest they make twice as much
cell wise as we do here so it would be a
huge turbo charge to my career as far as
that goes
as far as my family goes everybody that
my wife and i know are here
um so we would be going up there alone
um
i have a house that i'm building here um
about 560 000
um in a house that i have right now that
i would be selling to put money down on
that house um housing up there for
something along the same lines is about
200 000 more so does that does it make
sense to go out there financially
um well family-wise
well you got two issues here you've got
the relational
and then you've got the financial
because i think the professional side if
it was just that i think you'd probably
be jumping at this is that true
yeah yeah
so i mean how open is your wife how open
are you
to
leaving before we get to the financial
piece how open are you to leaving
everybody in phoenix and heading to this
opportunity
they actually paid to fly us out there
to take a look around and to commute
some communities and some houses so we
were there
this last weekend and my wife loved it i
mean obviously the
the temperature outside is a whole lot
better right now it's probably a hundred
and something in phoenix and right it
was 60 degrees there so that was nice um
so your wife is not really tied to
phoenix to the point where she's pushing
back against us going i don't know
brandon i don't know that's what i'm
trying to determine seems like she's oh
yeah she's probably more than i am okay
uh and how big of a deal is it to you i
mean how seriously how big of a deal is
are you worried about some guilt are you
worried about some pressure from family
if you were to leave
um no it's more just
uh i guess i don't see them all that
much anyway we're kind of introverted
stay home and do our he'll keep up on
instagram right it'll be fine well you
just answered that question
yeah but but it's i guess the fact that
on my way home i could do like i did
yesterday stop by and talk to my brother
about this situation or something else i
wouldn't be able to just do that and
yeah you'd have to facetime him you'd
have to facetime him yeah yeah you're
introverts anyway okay you know what i'm
gonna pass the baton to george because i
think this is a financial play right
here i mean i think the professional
side it's a no-brainer and it feels like
on the relational side it's a no-brainer
so george we got one more box to walk
through the timing is wonky because you
said you're building a house
yeah so i put six grand earnest cash
down um i could try to get that back i
doubt i would but that would be
something that i asked for the company
to pay me back for to move up there oh
it's part of your moving car
either way yeah
i'd likely get some sort of um moving
bonus relocation bonuses
they've not offered you the job yet
correct
my my boss
said it's about a 99 chance um we have
support from the current people at the
facility that would be moving up to the
new area and the the president is all
for it um and the
other one of the other vps um so i got a
lot of support and is the 130 a shot in
the dark i mean is that a wet finger in
the air
or is that reasonable what's that the
130 that you'd be you'd be asking
he he originally told me somewhere
between 120 and 130. oh but i think it's
reasonable okay just want to make sure
you weren't just hoping
yeah that's a number that they threw out
there okay
cool well if you can get out of this
house what would your house sell for
that you're in
about 436
450. and what's your equity
we owe about 195
190 something so you could you could net
over 200 grand
to put down on a house there maybe you
even rent for a year when you get to the
new area to figure out where you want to
live
right is that a possibility
yeah okay
so i'm good with that if you guys
take your time with them finding
somewhere
okay can you can you get a house though
because you said the cost of the housing
there is about 200 grand more i think
you can beat that i don't know what a
reasonable house cost for you guys in
that area 600 grand 500
up there yeah
700 72
750. well i just look at it facts and
math and go all right go to the mortgage
calculator at ramseysolutions.com and
start playing around with the numbers
15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a quarter of our take-home pay
how much down payment do we need to put
down in order to make that happen and if
it's not going to be within the
parameters right now then just go rent
for a year and figure out what area you
want to live and start to feel out in
the market you got to continue to cool
off and buy when you're ready let me say
this you could rent two years when so
when stacey and i when we relocated from
atlanta to come join ramsey solutions we
rented for two years because we had
three kids and we wanted to be
absolutely certain
what the best place was for us it's a
large area i'm sure it's a large area
there and so we had a lot of different
ways we could go and we ran it for two
years as one of the best decisions we
ever made no need to rush brandon does
your wife work outside the home
yeah she just graduated dental school
she's uh an assistant so she makes 18 an
hour here about 38 grand i think up
there might be a few more bucks an hour
maybe somewhere around 25 bucks an hour
so there's that as well great that would
help so what's your gut telling you
we've already walked i feel really good
about this yeah what are you feeling
what are you feeling brandon what do you
how do you feel
i mean i i think it's a huge opportunity
i don't think it'd be a bad decision
there's a lot more stuff outdoors you to
do with the kids we got two girls nine
and 11. um so one is going into sixth
grade so i don't think she really has
like
lifetime you know best friends but here
coming up pretty quick she will so yeah
if we were to make a move somewhere this
would be the time i say trust your gut
we've walked through all the different
things to think through i think george
is right do some more uh mortgage
calculation stuff with that great
resource couple more visits up there and
then go hey you know what we're just
gonna make this move because it's an
absolute win for us professionally it's
a win for us
relationally
the wife is on board girls will be fine
you said you're an introvert don't see
your family much anyway and so
now financially we're gonna ease into
this yeah and by ranting for a while i
found that you'll find whatever you're
looking for when it comes to life change
if you look for fear it's true and all
the reasons you're gonna miss all then
that's what your life is gonna be but if
you look at the upside man i'm so
excited about this new neighborhood and
where we're going to live and all the
friends we're going to make and i've
moved across country multiple times and
i love my family we talk we facetime
but i'm real happy with my decisions but
that initial fear is real so you've got
to overcome that with some facts some
logic and reality but i'm pumped for you
man it's a big opportunity i'm taking it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so ken we've been talking about
insurance a lot lately and i'm sure
everyone knows about auto insurance life
insurance hopefully term life have been
hanging around the show for a little
while but there are some crazy types of
insurance out there i did a little
instagram reel and tick tock video about
oh did you i haven't seen that yet i'll
head over you got to get on social media
yeah yeah yeah so it's hard to believe
that these types of insurance are real
people actually buy them so i want to
get your take on these crazy titles oh
you're hitting me with some crazy oh
this is very exciting let's start with
this one you'll enjoy this okay death by
laughter insurance come on this is for
comedians who are so funny they're
afraid someone will croak
laughing themselves you gotta be kidding
me so this is a protectionary insurance
this is a real fear for people like you
accountability well for funny guys i'm a
funny guy but i don't walk around
worrying about killing somebody with my
with my comedy so this is a result of
our litigious society
our justice system has run amok
you wanted commentary i'm bringing if i
if i lose my breath because i'm laughing
so hard i can nelson
i die because i'm not in good health or
it's just some freak of nature situation
and the family's gonna sue the comedian
it's ridiculous the good news is you and
i don't have to worry about that ken
yeah we're not that funny the people in
the lab they're telling us the audience
out there
there we go yeah all right and uh this
lady just passed oh she's okay stay
alive
so ken you you love your sports i do
love sports you also love fantasy
football here's the crazy part i love
fantasy you can insure your fantasy
football team so that's you can cut your
losses if a player gets injured now see
i see no problem with that that's solid
that's solid insurance i'm kidding relax
everybody see this is ridiculous how
much money are you putting in your
fantasy football that you feel you need
to insure your team if you're getting
insurance for something that has the
word fantasy in it well that's a whole
other issue you need to take a good hard
look in the mirror about your life
choices you need to go to church well
that's for another day all right here's
a personal favorite of mine okay death
by falling coconut insurance oh come on
that's a real one death by falling
coconuts and here's the thing i found
out by google 150 people die a year from
falling coconuts what are they doing
shaking the tree
looking for this problem if you're a
coconut farmer and you're not wearing a
helmet you know it could be an issue
but this is a rider on some life
insurance policies i guess if you're
around coconut i gotta tell you
something um i i i was in the uh i was
in the caribbean uh forget where it was
now maybe st thomas
and i or where i don't know maybe it's
haiti i can't remember it got a coconut
right out of the tree
guy i'm with got a machete
because you know i don't have a machete
you don't carry one around i'm not i'm a
diver right no and the guy just
chops the top of the coconut off drank
right out of it unbelievable organic
coconut water now i could see myself
choking on that and dying but not the
coconut falling on my head yeah yeah
this is ridiculous avoid that one uh
this is one for rachel cruz but she's
not here for all the conspiracy
theorists oh lord help us alien
abduction insurance
now this is a tricky one ken because you
have to have a confirmed sighting of an
alien to file a claim right good luck
the very absurdity of that language i
want to see the insurance processor who
goes along with that conversation who
gets to watch what this is this is
absolute pure theft
that insurance companies would steal
people's money over something this
stupid they ought to go you know what um
here's some prozac go see a professional
well for the conspiracy theorists out
there i mean you can make a killing from
just
price gouging them for all kinds of
crazy types of insurance who knows this
is the nuttiest thing i've heard in a
while well here's one that's even
nuttier and this is the last one that
i'm going to hit you with the coconut
death by coconut it's even crazy i can't
believe it after the rapture pet care oh
my gosh so here's the deal these are
crazy christians so this is now praying
on crazy exact christians so the
atheists out there are going hey let's
take advantage of these people if the
rapture happens and fido's still here
the left-behind atheist will take care
of fido
what do you think about that i this is
mental illness now i've got two french
bullets it's just truly mental illness
i'm not doing after the rapture pet care
i'm not doing before the rapture pet
care apparently i don't know if this is
true ten bucks for three pets quite the
bargain ten bucks a month for three i
don't know that's a good question i
gotta look into this i mean i wanna be a
good deal might be a good deal who knows
just do it in case you know yeah i wanna
know how that gets paid out and the care
for that one i have questions because
there's there are some people that are
going to be left behind
a fabulous book series for those of you
who haven't read that i'm more of a
movie guy kurt cameron
i still can
i promise you if i see a pair of folded
pants on a bed i get nervous i go oh my
gosh it's happening oh please get back
to the phones i can't i can't handle it
right now i i do have questions though i
have a fear of the clothes ken because
of that movie right this is trauma i'm
trying to get back to the pet like who
pays that out who's taking care of them
don't ask questions you don't want
people going to hell
anyways i don't know this is is this
real james these are real insurance look
them up
all right all joking aside there's a lot
of insurance options out there some
crazier than others and it should be
obvious that you don't need abduction
insurance uh but it can be tough to
figure out which ones you do need to
protect your finances as you do the baby
steps and you build wealth so if you
want to know the right kinds of
insurance to get it's a very short list
and i'm gonna walk you through that in a
free five-day video series called
confidence in your coverage in less than
three minutes a day i'm going to walk
you through the types of coverage you
need and why and i promise you after the
rapture pet care is not on the list so
go to ramseysolutions.com confidence and
sign up for that free guide today you'll
have a good time
there you go ken
all right wow
i didn't even know that was back where
ken belongs on the phones elizabeth
joins us in denver elizabeth welcome to
the show
hi there hey how can we help
well so a little brief background of
what's going on is i have managed to
accrue almost 50k in credit card debt no
loans no car no house none of that just
credit card debt
just credit cards because i've just not
been able to work enough in the world
climate that started two years ago i had
to have some serious dental work i had
to have
a grad level program that wasn't a
graduate school and therefore not
financial aid oriented that i paid for
out of pocket via credit card and so as
well just accrued from normal living
stuff with those other
uh exceptions and
i'm wondering if you have of course
you'll have questions but like what is
the best direction at tackling this debt
when i'm not yet making enough money to
really start paying it off quickly and
the interest fee each month combined
with
the payments i'm making on the minimum
it's like no progress what's the
interesting really unnecessary
the interest rates are different on each
card it's 17 on one 16 and 15 on another
oh my gosh
much in actual
what was the grad level
program for are you working in the field
i'm working in that field now i've just
finished that program it was a coaching
program
and what kind of coaching just starting
off
health coaching
and so how much are you making right now
in that field
well that's the thing is just starting
out in that field i'm now working on the
whole entrepreneurial aspect of
garnering the clients i need
to make a full-time income and i'm not
anywhere can you work for someone else
i could i think i'm looking into
different jobs to go work for different
companies as a health coach yes
okay i'm gonna have george walk you
through our debt snowball and getting
out of debt but i'm gonna coach you up
here on kind of my area of focus and
that is income related
this is one of the hottest job economies
we've ever seen and it still is
it still is no matter what you're seeing
in the news
now is one of the best times for you to
go get a what i'm going to call a day
job meaning it does not have to be
health coach related because you've got
to get rid of this debt you've got the
qualification in training to be a health
coach it is an entrepreneurial venture
anyway which means it's one customer at
a time unless you do what george says
where you go
work maybe for an established company
that has a
uh stable of health coaches but i don't
think that's what you want to do and
that's fine but right now actually i do
want to do something
i would rather do that than work any
other ordinary day job i would love
working with a company where i could
coach people for the company well i
appreciate that does that exist close by
you in denver
it does exist somewhere and i've been
looking you better go get it but until
then until then you better go make some
income
george yeah elizabeth so we don't have
time we're up against a break but what
i'm gonna do is gift you financial peace
university it's nine lessons but i want
you to do is just watch the first two
for now it's on budgeting it's on baby
step one and two and we're gonna also
with that give you every dollar premium
so that you can lay out all of your
income all of your expenses and figure
out where the leaks are and start to
make some progress that might mean
getting some extra jobs some side jobs
might mean cutting some things but this
is a fire you're paying 17 interest on
50k worth of debt we've got to attack
this so hang on the line austin's gonna
pick up we're going to give you fpu as
well as every dollar it's all part of
ramsey plus for one year call us back if
you need any help
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 15 16
better is a little with the fear of the
lord than great treasure
and trouble with it
stephen covey said i am not a product of
my circumstances i am a product of my
decisions
that'll preach
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they're 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they will remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more just use the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal today's question
comes from jeremy in north carolina i'm
26 and i've made some bad financial
decisions i'm in baby step two and i'm
trying to find higher paying jobs in my
degree field i have a bachelor's degree
in business management
as well as an associate degree in
business administration
i'm working 45 plus hours a week but i
only earn 25 to 30 000 a year i don't
have any housing expenses only utilities
my only debts are 4 000 in credit cards
and 15 000 in student loans how can i
increase my income
and how do i budget on a weekly paycheck
in the meantime
i'll take the first half of that
question and increase the income listen
when someone who has a business
management degree and they go hey how
can i you know get promoted or make more
money in my field
look this is leadership
you're technically saying i have a
degree in business leadership but the
problem is
and i don't want to hurt anybody's
feelings i'm just going to keep it real
a business management degree
um is not worth a whole lot it just
isn't because the way to learn how to
manage in a way to learn how to lead is
to follow
and and and so what i would do is you're
only making 25 to 30 000 a year with a
degree you got to set your sights higher
this is a wonderful wonderful job
economy as i've been saying and i talk
about it every day on the ken coleman
show look
you can make way more money than this so
you got to go get yourself a role in a
business because that is your background
and you have some experience in it and
don't worry about am i in leadership
right now i just need to make more money
now that's one thing that's leveling up
and getting a better job
maybe in a larger company or a healthier
small business the second thing is you
are in a situation where you can knock
this debt out pretty quickly so maybe
it's a second job again
part-time jobs whether it be bartending
waiting tables delivering stuff they
that industry is
begging for people
you can go make more money uh if it's
two or three part-time jobs until you
find that better uh business job so that
would be my focus right now so that he
can get out of debt because he has no
housing yeah which is great because that
should free up some margin if we're
doing a budget and he asked how do i do
a budget on a weekly paycheck in the
meantime well just like you would if you
got paid every two weeks so use every
dollar you're going to list every single
paycheck in the income section in the
expenses section we've got to give every
single dollar a name and actually pay
attention to where your money's going
and go you know what i could cut that
and i didn't get a better deal on the
insurance and i'm getting a tax refund i
need to change my withholding and all of
a sudden you get creative and you find
room in your budget so i just did some
quick uh napkin math here ken if he
found a job 15 hours a week that puts
him at 60 hours that 15 hours a week at
20 an hour which is reasonable right now
very reasonable that'll give him an
extra 300 bucks a week
that's 1200 a month yeah and so now you
go we got 1200 a month to throw at the
19 000 in debt that's right we're gonna
be debt-free in a year this is this is
very very doable but we've got to really
ratchet down our spending and increase
our income that's how you create margin
we got to spend less and make more
that's it so you can do this man yep
all right let's go to the phones melissa
joins us up next in san diego melissa
welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure
um so my question is so my dad has a
paid off house that's worth
approximately 1.4 million dollars um
he's thinking that he's going to have a
forced retirement possibly in the next
coming weeks to months
um in his retirement my dad would not be
able to afford the property taxes and
the upkeep to remain in this property
um
and my dad has done a lot with the
property and he doesn't want to lose it
outside of the family
and my husband and i just had twin boys
which are now 10 months old
and my dad has recently proposed the
idea of
allowing us to take over the house
and building a granny flat on the
property
that he would live in
my husband and i own a house and we owe
approximately 199 000 on our house
in the current market we're estimating
to get approximately 525 000
uh for our house which would net us
approximately 300 000
which we would use to fund the build for
the granny flat on his property that he
would live in
and my dad recently got an estimate for
the new builds that would be
approximately 340 thousand dollars
so since the numbers are so close we're
wondering if it would be a smart idea to
get a construction loan
to fund the rest of the project
um
our expenses at my dad's house that we'd
be moving into are approximately 400
more per month
than the house we're currently living in
and that's just with extras such as like
pool maintenance landscaper that kind of
thing
um and this is a way for our family to
move into a bigger residence
without having much of an increase
um
melissa it feels like this is a recipe
for disaster and resentment because you
don't own the house and you're going to
put 300 000 in for him to live in it
while you pay all these extra
maintenance fees
what's the plan for ownership
uh we would have to sit down and and
that's like all the legalities but
basically i mean he owns the house
outright so it just means i think he
needs to sell this house downsize and
you guys live your life and move on yeah
that just feels like the best plan for
relationally and financially
and i got to tell you a big question
mark for me melissa was uh 340 000
for us for a place for him to live on
the property he didn't need that much
space
i understand the cost yeah i mean i
understand it's expensive to build
anything but he don't need that big of a
place so that was a big red flag on top
of everything else
okay
and you're saying he's going to be
retiring does he have money out because
he's that doesn't free up any cash flow
for him really other than what you're
adding to it
yeah no he would just be living off of
the retirement of what he has but like i
said just with with the way that the
market is here the
like the price to move anywhere else
would be
you know almost as expensive because he
owns the house outright he has like the
solar panel so he doesn't really pay
much of an electrical staying in the
house because of solar panels though i
mean i just want him to make could he
get a place for 800 900 000 is he on his
own
no it's him and my stepmom and then my
sister as well she's just finishing up
the last couple years of high school
yeah but they don't need all the space
is what you're saying it's a giant house
it sounds like correct yeah and then
we're eventually going to be having to
move up in house in a couple years so my
husband and i were thinking we were
moving up in house in a couple of years
the problem is you're at the whim of of
his decisions with his property after
you've put in 340 thousand dollars
so that just feels like it's gonna get
messy
okay even if we like sat down and got
like if we were to end up selling the
house we would always leave with the
amount that we put in
potentially but even then that's that's
not an appreciating asset i'd rather you
get a house where the house is
increasing in value instead of you just
getting your piece back
what happens what happens to the estate
when he passes i'm assuming he's thought
through this and has got this in writing
yes
yeah yes who gets the help
it's my sister and i that we would be
splitting
basically his effects
which to split it you guys would need to
sell it to get money correct
yeah or he mean he has other other
investments outside of the home he has
his retirement and some other stocks and
stuff like that that he has so it's just
really messy melissa do you feel it
i mean i think without
that
it's hard to let go because i mean like
i said we're thinking of moving into a
bigger house and we can like have a five
bucks because what the house that we
live in now is only twelve hundred
square feet
and that's my name and our two boys we
would eventually move into something
bigger
and if we can move into a bigger house
yeah but you're moving into a place with
family members
now we're all one big happy family
[Music]
are you guys
debt-free no we have uh well obviously
we have the house and then we have um
sixty thousand dollars on a student loan
okay here's my plan for do you have an
emergency fund or savings
yeah
okay well the baby steps would tell you
let's throw all the money into debt
except four thousand dollars let's clean
up this uh student loan let's get the
fully funded emergency fund then let's
start saving up for our next house so
that's what i would be doing and maybe
you could put 400 down once you sell
this house and get a 700 000 house that
would be more suitable for your family
so i'm going to run my own path i'm not
going to mess with the whole family
estate piece it just feels too messy
that's just my take appreciate the call
that puts this hour up the ramsay show
in the books thank you to my co-host ken
coleman to austin and will and james and
zach and andrew in the booth and you
america appreciate you guys listening in
until the next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give outrageously
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you